Fire Emblem is widely regarded as one of
the Premier tactical role-playing
franchises it's responsible for
popularizing the genre to Legions of
console Gamers and over the years has
had numerous entries that introduced
beloved characters freshened up the
fighting mechanics and even introduced
new social systems to celebrate the
launch of the latest game Fire Emblem
and Gage here is the history of Fire
Emblem
after the release of famicom wars in
1988 known in the west as Advanced Wars
intelligence systems began work on a new
game that aimed to combine the strategy
elements of famicom wars with the Deep
story and memorable characters players
expected from an RPG inspired by games
like Final Fantasy 3 Fire Emblem Creator
shuzo kaga wanted players to become
emotionally invested in their units and
wanted the events of the story to differ
depending on how people played I think I
made an RPG that borrows the frame of a
strategy game he said in a 1990
interview
[Music]
that ambition would lead to a game
called Fire Emblem shadow dragon and the
blade of light it followed the plight of
Mars an exiled prince in search of a
powerful Sword and the fire emblem in
order to kill an evil priest and a
resurrected dark dragon the game used a
turn-based battle system and introduced
mechanics that would become caught to
the Fire Emblem franchise like Arenas
promoting certain units into specialized
roles once they'd leveled up enough and
even permanently losing the characters
that fell in battle unfortunately the
game didn't review very well receiving
criticism from gaming magazines that its
Graphics were unimpressive and the
hybrid nature of the game was
complicated sales were initially low but
for mitsu reviewer nakaji wrote about
fire emblem in his column and that
combined with positive word of mouth led
to the game's sales picking up enough
that a sequel was ordered
shadow dragon and the blade of light was
re-released on the Virtual Console in
Japan over the years but America didn't
get to experience it until 2009 when it
was remade for the Nintendo DS under the
name Fire Emblem shadow dragon follow
the story of Prince as he defends his
country and tries to bring peace to the
continent in
[Music]
Fire Emblem shadow dragon it included
new chapters and characters
wait you don't know Marth what game is
he even from you don't know Fire Emblem
I don't know what's that for the 30th
anniversary of Fire Emblem the original
NES game was officially localized into
English and released digitally on the
eShop for a limited time
two years after the launch of the first
game intelligent systems released Fire
Emblem Gaiden a Side Story to the
original game hence the name Gaiden the
story takes place on a completely
different continent that was Split in
Two by feuding sibling Gods it follows
two characters both who lead their own
armies as they try to reunite it
intelligent systems attempted to tackle
some of the criticism leveled at the
gameplay of the first game by adding an
Overworld and towns to explore but
reviewers found the two games to be
starkly different complaining the
guidance strategic elements were
noticeably weaker
it was remade for the 3DS under the name
Fire Emblem Echoes Shadows of Valencia
and released worldwide in 2017. the
remake decided to keep the more
controversial elements of gaiden's
gameplay but modernize them for a new
audience the Remake also included new
artwork fully voiced characters and new
cutscenes
via emblem mystery of the emblem was
released for the SNES in 1994 and is
split into two parts referred to as
books book one is a remake of shadow
dragon and the blade of light with book
2 being a continuation of the game's
events with the same characters the
story was even adapted into a home
release animated series and so it began
a Headley a Dark Continent filled with a
million unknown dangers but low interest
meant only two episodes were ever
released in 2010 the game was remade for
the DS under the name new mystery of the
emblem as part of the 20th anniversary
celebrations for the Series in 1997 an
episodic Fire Emblem story known as BS
Fire Emblem was released in Japan via
teleview these downloadable episodes
were remade and released for new mystery
of the emblem under the name new Arcania
Chronicles
[Music]
1996's Fire Emblem genealogy of the holy
war was the first game in the series to
feature special skills and the now
iconic Fire Emblem weapons triangle a
rock paper scissors style system where
Lance's beat swords swords beat axes and
axes beat Lancers
another unique twist is that the game is
split into two story arcs with the
characters and pairings of the game's
first generation directly impacting the
second characters in the first
generation can fall in love and even
have children for the game's second
generation who inherit stats from their
parents despite many unofficial fan
translations genealogy of the holy war
has sadly never been released outside of
Japan it did however Inspire Fire Emblem
Awakening a title that would arrive many
years later
Fire Emblem Thrasher 776 didn't have the
easiest start Not only was the SNES game
released some years after Nintendo's
latest N64 Home console had hit the
market it was originally released via
the japan-only Nintendo Power service
where users would download certain SNES
and Game Boy games onto flash cartridges
at special kiosks in stores a boxed
version became available the next year
making it one of the snes's swan song
titles sadly the game was never released
outside of Japan the game takes place
during the events of genealogy of the
holy war and introduced new gameplay
features such as adding a fog of War to
some maps capturing enemies and even a
fatigue system where units that had
overexerted themselves would have to
hang back until recovered
after the release of genealogy of the
holy war the next Fire Emblem Home
console release was set to launch on the
Nintendo 64 DD peripheral the game was
completely scrapped due to the failure
of the 64 DD and intelligent systems
began working on a new Fire Emblem title
for the Game Boy Advance
[Applause]
binding blade was the first Fire Emblem
title to be released on a handheld
console launching in Japan in 2002 but
that wasn't the first time audiences had
seen binding Blade's main character Roy
despite Fire Emblem being unavailable
outside of Japan at this point Marth and
Roy were both fighters in 2001's Super
Smash Brothers Melee a game that was and
still is readily available in the west
fan reaction to the two characters was
positive as was the reaction to the
release of Advanced Wars in the west and
this encouraged intelligent systems and
Nintendo to bring the strategy series to
the West
[Music]
the drums of War are beating no man can
be trusted
[Music]
what happened to Dorca
I put poison in his mutton
[Music]
and your strategy build your army trust
nobody Fire Emblem the Blazing blade or
just fire emblem in the west is a
prequel to The Binding blade and was
designed with introducing newcomers to
the series in mind for example it had a
tutorial Fire Emblem was a hit in the
west garnering critical Acclaim Gamespot
gave it an 8.9 out of 10 with our
reviewer writing maybe we'll never know
why it's taken so long for us to see a
fire emblem game but it turns out to
have been well worth the wait this is a
deep story-rich strategy Saga that
shouldn't be missed by fans of the genre
willing to give up some Freedom or
console role-playing fans interested in
trying something new while a success
it's still important to note that the
binding blade still hasn't seen a
western release so Western audiences are
still technically in the dark as to how
future events with these characters
would unfold
[Music]
after the success of Fire Emblem it
didn't take long for another game to
come along Fire Emblem The Sacred Stones
launched the next year in Japan and in
early 2005 in North America a notable
addition to the Sacred Stones was a
freely traversable world map allowing
players to move around chapters and
engage in skirmishes which For Better or
Worse meant that players could easily
overpower their army if they were
struggling and avoid some of the
Tactical elements of the game this was
the first time since Fire Emblem Gaiden
the idea had been re-explored and it
wouldn't be until Fire Emblem Awakening
that it would be utilized again Sacred
Stones reviewed really well but was
criticized for reusing graphics and
sound from 2003's Fire Emblem and not
evolving the gameplay much gamespot's
Greg cassavin wrote one could easily
assume that a portable game such as this
couldn't live up to the depth and
quality of a full-blown strategy or
role-playing experience on consoles or
the PC but in that case one would simply
be mistaken
Path of Radiance launched worldwide for
the GameCube in 2005 and made the jump
to 3D while it was something new for the
series there was criticism that the
presentation lost some of the charm of
the 2D games the gameplay saw a lot of
minor but welcome adjustments like
awarding bonus XP that you can use on
your weaker backline units and a new
shape-shifting race that can't attack in
their humanoid form but present much
more of a challenge after they've
transformed players who owned Game Boy
Advance Fire Emblem titles could even
use the Link cable to unlock bonuses
[Music]
thank you
a sequel radiant Dawn came to the Wii
two years later but those hoping for
another standout entry in the series
would be disappointed while it was
praised for its stylish cel-shaded
cutscenes and the ability to import save
data from Path of Radiance to unlock
boosts and transfer supports radiant
Dawn came under some criticism its plots
which our reviewer at the time called
laughable just didn't land and the game
was frustratingly difficult despite
releasing on the Wii it didn't make use
of the motion controls either which some
saw as a missed opportunity radiant Dawn
took the Fire Emblem franchise to a low
Point despite the Newfound popularity in
the west the games weren't selling as
well as intelligent systems and Nintendo
hoped however the team was given one
more chance and told that if their next
Fire Emblem title didn't sell over 250
000 units the franchise was done for
the development team wanted to make this
final game with no regrets and so looked
at the previous games to incorporate
various gameplay mechanics into this
next one Fire Emblem Awakening they also
worked harder to ensure that the
characters were fleshed out and the
story was compelling it reincorporated
the free roaming map and the idea that
characters could pair up and have
children to help bring in new fans it
even made the series Mainstay permadeath
optional to create longevity it utilized
the 3DS StreetPass feature to fight and
recruit avatars from other players and
DLC was later released that featured
Maps characters and even episodes from
previous games Fire Emblem Awakening
launched for the 3DS in 2012 and saved
the franchise not only did the game hit
the sales Target but eclipsed it
becoming the fastest selling Fire Emblem
game so far
[Music]
we are your family we will succeed with
you at our side I make my own fate
via emblem Fates for the 3DS took a page
from Pokemon's book for its release in
that it has two versions Birthright and
Conquest each version is dedicated to a
kingdom which is at odds with the
kingdom represented by the other game
both right follows the hoshido storyline
and is seen as more beginner friendly
and Conquest follows the kingdom of Noah
and was marketed more towards series
veterans your character was born in one
nation and kidnapped and adopted by the
other so you must choose who to back in
the upcoming War a third storyline where
you don't side with either kingdom was
later released as DLC
[Music]
go once you die spin-off time Tokyo
Mirage sessions is a fire emblem and
shin Megami tensei crossover game for
the Wii U that was later ported to the
switch taking place in a modern Tokyo
Fire Emblem heroes and villains appear
as mirages with the dastardly villains
stealing people's creative spirit in a
bid to take over the world the shin
Megami tensei and Fire Emblem heroes
team up with the latter acting similarly
to the demons or personas from the smt
and Persona games to the former laying
the foundations for the game's combat
Fire Emblem Heroes is a free to play IOS
and Android spin-off with gacha
mechanics while typical Fire Emblem
strategy combat is there you need to
earn or pay for orbs to add Heroes to
your team what is it Lisa
your body it's all a glow with a blue
light Chrome
another spin-off Fire Emblem Warriors is
a major departure for the Fire Emblem
series as it casts aside turn-based
tactical combat to adopt the hack and
slash muso system format that is the
specialty of the game's co-developer
Omega Force it also takes place in an
alternate Dimension sadly despite all
its exciting ideas Fire Emblem Warriors
didn't set the world on fire as it was
filled with frustrating performance
issues and poor AI nevertheless some
long time Fire Emblem fans enjoyed the
fresh ideas even if the execution had
its faults
anyway while Fire Emblem spin-offs and
collabs were plentiful fans were getting
antsy for another Mainline Fire Emblem
game
in 2019 their patience was rewarded with
Fire Emblem 3 houses for the Nintendo
switch players are cast as bileth a
mercenary turned teacher of one of three
houses see what they did there at garrig
Mark Monastery the game mixes classic
tactical Fire Emblem combat with more
social Sim mechanics between fights
you're free to roam the monastery to get
to know the students as well as teach
them lessons to improve their stats and
help them specialize into roles with
three routes to take through the game
this encourages replayability as
different units and story elements are
available depending on which house you
take under your wing critics praised the
balance of the school phase and the
combat phase with our own review
commenting that the game's rewarding
gameplay Loop and fleshed Out characters
made it hard to put down Fire Emblem 3
houses was a huge success and became the
best-selling Fire Emblem game to date
the characters of three houses proved so
popular that a spin-off Warriors game
was released in 2022 with them in the
spotlight once again in three hopes
bileth takes the antagonist role as the
appearance of your new playable
character shares has messed up the
timeline while combat is familiar to
anyone who has played a Warriors game
before three hopes did add some three
houses inspired downtime between
missions to help you get to know the
characters better and upgrade your
facilities making it a welcome game for
those who wanted to see more from the
Garrick Mark students which brings us to
Fire Emblem engage the latest Mainline
Fire Emblem release
[Music]
in standard Fire Emblem Fair a great
fell Dragon was sealed Away by Mighty
Heroes long ago but over time the seal
has faltered and the dragon is Awakening
once again by collecting 12 emblem rings
and teaming up with other Fire Emblem
heroes from previous games it's up to
you to defeat the evil for good
so there you have it the history of the
Fire Emblem series from 1990 all the way
to present day for more on Fire Emblem
engage including our review make sure
you subscribe to Gamespot on YouTube and
check out gamespot.com I'm on Twitter at
Lucy James games and I'll see you next
time